now we come to a more serious
application of the fact that the GCD is
a linear combination we're going to use
it to prove the prime factorization
theorem which we've talked about earlier
this is the unique prime factorization
theorem so let's begin by looking at a
technical property of primes which is
familiar but we're gonna need to prove
it if you believe in prime factorization
then this lemma which says that if P
divides a product it divides one or the
other of the components of the product
that's an immediate consequence of the
prime factorization theorem but we
mustn't prove it that way because we're
trying to use this to prove prime
factorization so how can I prove based
on the facts of the what we know about G
CDs without appealing to prime
factorization that if P is a prime and P
divides a product then it the then it
divides one of the components of the
product either the multiplier or the
multiplicand okay well here's how to
prove that suppose that P divides a B
but it doesn't divide a of course if it
does divide a I'm done so we might as
well assume that it doesn't divide a now
that means that since the only divisors
of the only devices of P are P and one
the only positive divisors of PRP and
one that if P doesn't divide a the GCD
of a and P is one all right now comes a
linear combination trick given that the
GCD of P and a is 1 that means that I
have a linear combination of a and P
that's equal to 1 si plus TP is equal to
1 for some coefficients S&T cool
multiply everything by B on the right so
that means that si B + TP B is equal to
1 times B but look at what we have now
the first term on the left is something
times a B and P divides a B so that
first term is divisible by P the second
term explicitly has a P in it so it's
certainly divisible by P so the left
hand saw
is a linear combination of multiples of
pay and therefore itself is a multiple
of pay which means the right-hand side
is a multiple of P and the right-hand
side is B so sure enough P divides B
we're done the very elegant little proof
that follows immediately from the fact
that you can express the GCD of two
numbers as a linear combination of those
numbers now this is the key technical
lemma that we need to prove unique
factorization a corollary of this that
I'm actually going to need is that if P
divides a product of more than two
things that P divides a product of a lot
of things it has to divide at least one
of them and this you could prove by
induction with the base case being that
it works for M equals 2 but it's not
very interesting and we're going to take
that for granted if P divides a product
of any size it divides one of the
components of the product all right now
we're ready to prove what's called the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic which
says that every integer greater than one
factors uniquely into a weakly
decreasing sequence of primes now the
statement of weakly decreasing is a
little bit technical and unexpected what
we want to say is that that it that a
number factors into the same set of
primes well it's not quite right because
the set of primes doesn't take into
account how many times each prime occurs
you could try to make a statement about
every number uniquely is a multiple of a
certain number of each kind of prime but
a slick way to do that is simply to say
take all the prime factors including
multiple occurrences of a prime and line
them up in weakly decreasing order and
when you do that that sequence is unique
ok
this fundamental theorum arithmetic is
also called the prime factorization
theorem and here's what it says when we
spell it out without using the words
weakly the crows weakly increasing or
weakly decreasing it says that every
integer and greater than one
has a unique factorization into primes
mainly it can be extremely it can be
expressed as a product of P 1 through P
K is equal to n with P 1 greater than
equal to P 2 greater than or equal to
each successive Prime in the sequence
with the smallest one last okay
let's do an example so there's a number
that was not chosen by accident because
I worked out what the factorization was
and it factors into the following weakly
decreasing sequence you start with the
prime 53 you follow by three occurrences
of 37 2 11s a seven and three threes and
the point is that if you try to express
this ugly number as a weakly decreasing
sequence of primes you're always going
to get exactly this sequence it's the
only way to do it alright how are we
going to prove that well let's suppose
that it wasn't true suppose that there
was some number that could be factored
in two different ways well by the well
ordering principle there's at least one
so we're talking about numbers that are
greater than one so there's a least
number greater than one that can be
factored in two different ways suppose
that it's n so what I have is that N is
a product P 1 through P K and it's equal
to another product q1 through qm where
the peas and the Q's are all prime and
these two weakly decreasing sequences
are not the same they differ somehow ok
so the we can assume that the peas are
listed in a weakly decreasing order and
the Q's are likewise in listed in weakly
decreasing order now the first
observation is suppose the q1 is equal
to p1 well that's not really possible
because if Q 1 is equal to p1 then I
could cancel the P 1 from both sides and
I would get that P 2 through PK is equal
to Q 2 through QM and these would still
be different since I that were different
and I took the same thing from their
beginning I'm left with a smaller number
that does not have a unique factor as
contradicting the minimality of n so in
short it's not possible for q1 to equal
p1 so one of them has to be greater we
may as well assume the q1 is bigger than
p1 okay
so q1 is bigger than P 1 and P 1 is
greater than equal to all the other Peas
so in fact q1 is bigger than every one
of the peas well that's gonna reach a
contradiction because of the cut of the
corollary what I know is that q1 divides
n and n is the product of the peas and
since Q divides the product of the peas
by the corollary it's gotta divide one
of them q1 must divide P I for some I
but that contradicts the fact that qi q
one's bigger than p i that's not
possible for the smaller number to
divide the larger number to divide the
smaller number and we're done and we
have proved the unique factorization
theorem